splątanie kwantowe pozwala cząstkom być ze sobą powiązanymi bez względu na odległość między nimi – to jest tak sprzeczne z intuicją,
że nawet Einstein nie wierzył, że jest prawdziwe. W dzisiejszym odcinku Qiskit w klasie porozmawiamy o tym, jak twierdzenie Bella
udowodniło, że Einstein
się mylił. Witaj w Qiskit w klasie. W tej serii będziemy używać Qiskit, aby zgłębiać podstawowe koncepcje powszechnie
omawiane na kursach związanych z obliczeniami kwantowymi. Każdemu filmowi towarzyszy interaktywny moduł
podlinkowany w opisie poniżej, więc koniecznie go sprawdź. W filmie o kwantowych monetach omówiliśmy, jak pomiar
kwantowej superpozycji jest z natury procesem probabilistycznym, podobnym pod pewnymi względami do rzutu monetą, ale skąd wiemy,
że tak jest? Czy możliwe, że cząstka kwantowa potajemnie kryje z góry określony wynik pomiaru, ale my jakoś nie możemy
uchwycić tej informacji w naszej teorii? We wczesnych dniach mechaniki kwantowej to pytanie było przedmiotem
gorących debat, z dwoma głównymi obozami. W jednym obozie był Einstein, który wierzył, że mechanika kwantowa jest niekompletna,
to znaczy, że brakowało jej pewnych zmiennych koniecznych do pełnego opisu układu. Einstein uważał, że
te tak zwane ukryte zmienne, jeśli zostałyby odkryte, rozwiązałyby niektóre pozornie paradoksalne i probabilistyczne
aspekty mechaniki kwantowej. W drugim obozie był Max Born. Born twierdził,
że probabilistyczny opis dany przez mechanikę kwantową jest wszystkim, co natura nam daje. Innymi słowy,
nie chodzi tylko o to, że nie znamy stanu cząstki przed jej pomiarem – chodzi o to, że cząstka nie ma żadnego określonego stanu
przed pomiarem. Przez dziesięciolecia wielu uważało ten spór za kwestię filozoficzną, która może nigdy
nie zostać rozstrzygnięta. W końcu, aby czegoś się dowiedzieć o układzie, musimy go zmierzyć. Jak możemy się dowiedzieć
czegokolwiek o naturze stanu przed jego pomiarem? Wtedy, w 1964 roku, fizyk
John Bell znalazł sposób. W swoim artykule Bell zbadał korelacje statystyczne między pomiarami pary
splątanych cząstek. Jeśli przed pomiarem stany cząstek były wyznaczone przez nieznane ukryte
zmienne, Bell stwierdził, że ich korelacje miały górną granicę. Z drugiej strony, kiedy obliczył
korelacje przewidywane przez mechanikę kwantową, odkrył, że naruszają tę granicę. Znalazł więc sposób, by raz
na zawsze odróżnić pogląd Einsteina od poglądu Borna. Pozostało tylko faktycznie eksperymentalnie
przetestować te korelacje na prawdziwych cząstkach, żeby sprawdzić, czy podlegają statystyce ukrytych zmiennych, czy też
naruszają tę regułę. Testy te były przeprowadzane z rosnącą precyzją i wyrafinowaniem
przez lata i należą do najbardziej znaczących eksperymentów współczesnej fizyki. Były tak przełomowe, że
przyniosły trzem fizykom Nagrodę Nobla w 2022 roku. Ale dziś każdy może przeprowadzić
test Bella. Potrzebujemy tylko trochę wiedzy o Qiskit i dostępu do komputera kwantowego IBM. W tym filmie
przeprowadzę cię przez logikę nierówności Bella, a następnie pokażę, jak możemy przetestować przewidywania Bella na komputerze kwantowym
IBM. Nierówność Bella obejmuje kilka różnych pomiarów i warstw logiki i może być
nieco trudna do śledzenia, ale przejdziemy przez nią krok po kroku i w końcu będzie warto. Zaraz pokażemy,
że splątanie jest realne, a Einstein się mylił. Niewielu ludzi może powiedzieć, że tego dokonało. A więc oto
co zaproponował Bell. Powiedzmy, że masz sposób na wytworzenie wielu kopii splątanej pary cząstek. Fizycznie
takie pary mogą być produkowane przez proces rozpadu, w którym jedna cząstka rozpada się na dwie. Jeśli oglądałeś film o eksperymencie
Sterna-Gerlacha, wiesz, że cząstki mogą mieć wewnętrzny moment pędu zwany
spinem. Powiedzmy, że cząstka o spinie zero rozpada się na dwie cząstki o spinie 1/2.
Wtedy każda z cząstek o spinie 1/2 może być zmierzona jako mająca spin plus 1/2 lub minus
1/2, zwany też spinem w górę lub spinem w dół. Ale ponieważ rozpadły się z cząstki o spinie zero, to te dwie muszą łącznie dawać
spin zero. Więc jeśli jedna jest zmierzona jako skierowana w górę, druga musi być
skierowana w dół i odwrotnie. Te cząstki tworzą splątaną parę, która wygląda tak.
Więc jeśli jedna jest zmierzona jako skierowana w górę, druga jest skierowana w dół i odwrotnie. Powiedzmy, że cząstka pierwsza odlatuje w lewo, czyli
w kierunku minus X, gdzie badacz, którego nazwiemy Lucas, mierzy jej
spin. Następnie cząstka druga podobnie odlatuje w prawo,
gdzie inna badaczka, Rihanna, może zmierzyć ten spin. Lucas i Rihanna mogą niezależnie
obracać swoje przyrządy pomiarowe, aby wybrać pomiar spinu swoich odpowiednich cząstek wzdłuż dowolnego kierunku
prostopadłego do kierunku ruchu cząstki. Jeśli wyślemy wiele kopii stanu splątanego do Lucasa
i Rihanny, mogą zbierać statystyki pomiarów. Jeśli zawsze mierzą wzdłuż tej samej osi, te statystyki nie będą
bardzo interesujące: za każdym razem, gdy jeden mierzy spin w górę, drugi mierzy spin w dół, i za każdym razem, gdy jeden mierzy spin
do przodu, drugi mierzy spin do tyłu, i tak dalej. Ale jeśli dwoje badaczy mierzy wzdłuż różnych osi, możemy znaleźć
coś bardziej interesującego. Dajmy Lucasowi i Rihannie trzy osie, wzdłuż których mogą
mierzyć. Nazwiemy te osie a, b i c, i są od siebie oddzielone
o 120°. Pytanie, które zadamy w tym eksperymencie, brzmi: jeśli Lucas i Rihanna mogą swobodnie mierzyć wzdłuż dowolnej z trzech
osi, jak często oboje uzyskają ten sam znak? Jasne jest, że jeśli Lucas i Rihanna mierzą wzdłuż tej samej osi,
powiedzmy osi a, nigdy nie mogą uzyskać tego samego znaku, ponieważ cząstki muszą łącznie dawać spin zero. Ale gdy wybierają
różne osie, jak będą skorelowane ich pomiary, jeśli w ogóle? Zdaniem Einsteina ten kwantowy
mechaniczny opis stanu cząstek jest niekompletny. Uważał, że muszą istnieć ukryte zmienne, które
z góry wyznaczają wynik wszystkich możliwych pomiarów spinu, bo bez tego splątane cząstki musiałyby jakoś
natychmiastowo komunikować wynik swojego pomiaru sobie nawzajem. Jeśli jedna zostałaby zmierzona jako
skierowana w górę gdzieś tutaj, ta druga musiałaby natychmiastowo wiedzieć, żeby być skierowana w dół gdzieś
tam. Te ukryte zmienne mogą być dowolnym skomplikowanym zestawem instrukcji dla wyników eksperymentów, ale chodzi o to,
że stan spinu każdej cząstki z osobna jest wyznaczony, więc żadna komunikacja nie jest konieczna.
WEBVTT
Eksperymentalnie oznaczałoby to, że pomiary dokonane przez Lucasa nie miałyby wpływu na cząstkę Rihanny i odwrotnie.
To mogłoby narzucić pewne ograniczenia na to, jak bardzo skorelowane mogą być dwa pomiary. Zdaniem Borna jednak ten stan
jest wszystkim, co można powiedzieć o parze cząstek przed pomiarem, więc pomiar jednej cząstki
wpływa na wynik pomiaru drugiej. Może to mieć różne implikacje dla korelacji między pomiarami. Zobaczmy, jak każda
teoria wpływa na te korelacje. W ujęciu ukrytych zmiennych istnieje tajny zestaw instrukcji przed
pomiarem, który już wyznacza to, co Lucas zmierzy wzdłuż każdej z trzech osi. Na przykład te
instrukcje mogą być: pozytywny, jeśli Lucas mierzy wzdłuż osi a,
pozytywny, jeśli mierzy wzdłuż b, i negatywny, jeśli mierzy wzdłuż c. Możemy
zapisać to jako plus a, plus b i minus c. Wtedy cząstka Rihanny
musiałaby mieć zmienne minus a, minus b i plus c, żeby zapewnić, że łączny
spin wzdłuż dowolnego kierunku wynosi zero.
Istnieje osiem zestawów możliwych instrukcji spełniających to ograniczenie zerowego spinu, więc za każdym razem, gdy do Lucasa i Rihanny wysyłana jest nowa para
cząstek, może zawierać dowolny z tych ośmiu zestawów instrukcji. Teraz chcemy
ustalić – zakładając, że cząstki zawierają jeden z tajnych zestawów instrukcji podanych w tabeli i
zakładając, że Lucas i Rihanna niezależnie wybierają, wzdłuż której z trzech osi mierzą – jakie jest
prawdopodobieństwo, że oboje zmierzą ten sam znak? Jeśli instrukcje są podane w wierszach 1 lub
8, to prawdopodobieństwo wynosi oczywiście zero, ponieważ dwie cząstki będą miały przeciwne znaki niezależnie od ich
osi pomiarowych. Ale co z instrukcjami w wierszu 2? Zmierzą te same znaki, jeśli
Rihanna mierzy wzdłuż c, a Lucas wzdłuż a lub b, albo jeśli Lucas
mierzy wzdłuż c, a Rihanna wzdłuż a lub b. To daje cztery na dziewięć
możliwych kombinacji pomiarów, które dadzą Lucasowi i Rihannie ten sam znak. Jeśli zrobimy to dla
każdego zestawu instrukcji, zobaczysz, że wiersze 3 do 7 również dają prawdopodobieństwo 4/9. Oznacza to, że jeśli
Einstein ma rację i ukryte zmienne takie jak te z góry wyznaczają wynik pomiarów, nie ma sposobu, żeby Lucas
i Rihanna kiedykolwiek zmierzyli ten sam znak z prawdopodobieństwem większym niż 4/9. To jest nierówność Bella: P mniejsze lub równe
4/9. I jak pokażemy, splątane cząstki naruszają tę wartość. Żeby zobaczyć, co przewiduje mechanika kwantowa,
powiedzmy, że Lucas mierzy wzdłuż a. Mogą się wydarzyć dwie rzeczy: albo zmierzy spin w górę,
wtedy Rihanna zmierzyłaby spin w dół wzdłuż a, albo zmierzy spin w dół i Rihanna zmierzyłaby spin w górę wzdłuż a. Ale
chcemy prawdopodobieństwa, że Rihanna zmierzy ten sam znak co Lucas wzdłuż dowolnej osi przez nią wybranej, nie tylko a. Jeśli
mierzy wzdłuż b lub c, robi się nieco bardziej skomplikowane. Okazuje się, że
jeśli wiesz, co Rihanna zmierzy ze 100% pewnością wzdłuż jednego kierunku, możesz obliczyć prawdopodobieństwa,
że zmierzy w górę lub w dół wzdłuż dowolnej innej osi, za pomocą odrobiny geometrii.
Jeśli twój stan zawsze daje spin w górę wzdłuż jednej osi, to prawdopodobieństwo zmierzenia spinu w górę wzdłuż innej osi
będzie równe kwadratowi cosinusa połowy kąta między tymi dwiema osiami. To nieco skomplikowane, ale
zaraz pokażę, co mam na myśli. Jeśli Lucas zmierzy spin w górę wzdłuż a, wiemy ze 100% pewnością, że Rihanna zmierzyłaby
spin w dół, gdyby mierzyła a. Możemy to przedstawić wektorem
w taki sposób. W tym przypadku kąty między tym wektorem a pozostałymi dwiema osiami pomiarowymi b i c wynoszą obydwa
60°. Więc połowa z tego to 30°, a cosinus
30° jest pokazany tutaj. Cosinus kwadrat
30° równa się 3/4. A co jeśli Lucas zmierzy spin w dół
wzdłuż a? Wiemy, że Rihanna zmierzyłaby spin w górę wzdłuż a, więc możemy narysować tutaj inny wektor. Teraz
ten wektor reprezentujący tę wiedzę jest oddalony o 120° od każdej z pozostałych dwóch osi b
i c. Więc możemy zastosować ten sam trik geometryczny, ale tym razem dostaniemy cosinus
60°. Więc cosinus kwadrat
60° równa się 1/4. Ponieważ Lucas jest jednakowo skłonny zmierzyć
spin w górę i spin w dół wzdłuż a, musimy uśrednić te dwa prawdopodobieństwa dla Rihanny. Dostajemy końcowe
prawdopodobieństwo, że Rihanna zmierzy ten sam znak co Lucas, wynoszące 1/2. Więc P
równa się 1/2. 1/2 jest większe niż 4/9, więc nierówność Bella jest naruszona.
Oznacza to, że dopóki obowiązują reguły mechaniki kwantowej, ukryte zmienne są niemożliwe. Teraz możemy użyć Qiskit i
komputera kwantowego IBM, aby przetestować nierówność Bella na prawdziwych pomiarach kwantowych. Możemy odwzorować stany spinu w górę i
spinu w dół cząstek Lucasa i Rihanny na stany zero i jeden qubitów w komputerze kwantowym. Weźmiemy
dwa qubity, jeden reprezentujący cząstkę Lucasa i jeden cząstkę Rihanny, i splączemy je tym quantum circuit.
Dwa qubity są reprezentowane przez dwa draty q0 i q1, a ta kombinacja
bramek X, Hadamard i cnot wytworzy ten sam splątany stan, który mieliśmy między cząstkami Lucasa i Rihanny. Teraz
musimy zmierzyć każdy qubit. Ustawimy pomiar Lucasa wzdłuż a, co powiemy, że jest osią Z. Następnie pomiar Rihanny
może być wzdłuż a, b lub c, więc będziemy potrzebować trzech oddzielnych circuits dla każdego z tych trzech przypadków. Ale w tym
filmie zrobimy tylko jeden. Możesz przejść do modułu podlinkowanego w opisie, żeby zobaczyć całość. Jeśli Rihanna mierzy wzdłuż
b, nasz circuit wygląda tak, gdzie ry to obrót o 120° w celu zmiany
osi pomiarowej Rihanny. Możemy użyć Qiskit Primitive sampler, żeby uruchomić ten eksperyment wiele razy i zbierać
statystyki z wynikowych pomiarów. Dwie kolumny 0 0 i 1 1 reprezentują momenty, gdy Lucas i
Rihanna zmierzyli ten sam znak, a o to nam chodzi. Więc prawdopodobieństwo zmierzenia obu cząstek mających ten
sam znak jest bliskie 1/2. To narusza nierówność Bella. Oznacza to,
WEBVTT
że dwie cząstki są splątane – każda z nich w jakiś sposób natychmiastowo zdaje się znać wyniki
pomiaru drugiej. Wciąż trwają pewne spory o to, jak dokładnie interpretować to
splątanie i co się dzieje, gdy mierzysz splątany stan, ale te pytania są bardziej filozoficzne.
Teoria jest w tym momencie dość niepodważalna: splątanie jest zdecydowanie realne i wiemy to dzięki Bellowi, jego
nierówności i licznym fizykom, którzy przeprowadzili eksperymenty, żeby ją przetestować. Jeśli chcesz być zaliczony do grona tych
fizyków i przeprowadzić własny test Bella na komputerze kwantowym, koniecznie zajrzyj do modułu nierówności Bella
podlinkowanego w opisie. Dzięki za oglądanie i do zobaczenia następnym razem.